[موسيقى]
لا لا داعي للتبرير ايها الامريكان لقد
كشفت روسيا تواجد جنودكم في اوكرانيا هكذا
فرط الاوكرانيون ابناء العم سام فكيف
سيكون الرد الروسي ووثائق البنتا تكشف
نقاط الضعف الاوكرانيه امام روسيا
يستفز العراقيين ليهاجم بوتين وفرنسا تغضب
الدب الروسي وتزود كييف باسلحه قد تغير
مجرى المعركه وكييف تعلن بدء هجومها
المضاد فهل بدات معركه الربيع هنغاريا
تعلنها لن نقف في وجه الدب الروسي والسيول
من التعزيزات تصل الى الخرطوم وعداد
الضحايا في ارتفاع وثلاثه سيناريوهات
وشيكه لانتهاء الحرب السودانيه وسلطات
مكون في خطر والمغرب ين خمسه مليارات
لتعزيز جيشه فهل هذا الانفاق الفلكي يدل
على حرب قد اقترب موعدها
واشنطن تتورط امام موسكو شيئا فشيئا تتورط
الولايات المتحده في الحرب الاوكرانيه
اكثر والاوضاع تزداد سوءا وها هي صحيفه
واشنطن بوست تفيد بان المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين يعترفون بشكل خاص بي ان عدد
من العمليات العسكريه في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه تجري تحت اشراف امريكيه بينما
كانت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه قد صرحت ان
دول النيتو تلعب بالنار وذلك بتزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه فما بالنا بالتدخل
الامريكي مباشره في الحرب هل تندلع
المواجهه المباشره بين الدب الروسي وابناء
العم سام من جانب اخرها هي فرنسا تطلق
وعودها بتزويد اوكرانيا بسفن وحافلات
لتشعل غضب موسكو فكيف سيرد الروس لترتفع
الحماسه لدى الاوكران حيث افادت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بان القوات الاوكرانيه
حاولت مهاجمه قاعده الاسطول في مدينه
مضيفه انه تم تدميرها جميعا دون وقوع
اصابات هناك اعلنها زلنسكي بان بوتين
سيخرج مهزوما من الاراضي الاوكرانيه كما
خرج صدام حسين خاسرا من الكويت مضيفا انه
بات يقاتل من اجل حياته الرد الروسي كان
على الارض حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان قواتها قتلت نحو
4070 جنديا اوكرانيا على خمسه محاور قتال
اساسيه واسقطت 38 طائره بدون طيار للعدو
في مناطق متفرقه خلال 24 ساعه ومن هناك
جاء الرد الاوكراني على هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه بصد القوات الاوكرانيه نحو 60
هجوما في المقابل قال الجيش الاوكراني انه
نفذ خلال الساعات الماضيه سلسله ضربات على
مواقع التمركز الروس داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه كما اسقط الدفاعاتها مروحيه
روسيه وسته طائرات مسيره وعلى ذات الصعيد
لا زالت اصداء تسريب الوثائق الامريكيه
تتردد في الارجاء حيث كشفت الوثائق مؤخرا
عن نقاط ضعف خطيره بالجيش الاوكراني قد
تكبده خسائر باهظه امام الروس على الارض
وتشمل هذه النقاط احتمال نفاذ الذخائر
المضاده للطائرات لدرجه انها قد تفقد
السيطره تماما على الاجواء وفق التسريبات
فهل اقتربت ذخيره اوكرانيا من النفاد حقا
ومن التسريبات الى الاستخبارات الامريكيه
والتي تعتقد انه من المستبعد ان تتمكن
اوكرانيا من السيطره على شبه القرم هذا
الصيف وذلك بحسب صحيفه
لكن هنا لمعهد دراسه الحرب بواشنطن راي
اخر حيث كشف المعهد ان كييف بدات هجومها
المضاد وذلك بنجاح القوات الاوكرانيه في
انشاء مواقع على الجانب الشرقي من نار
بنبرو الا ان موسكو نفت الامر جمله
وتفصيلاسكي يساعد موجه الهجوم المضاد حيث
اختار الرئيس الاوكراني عشره مسؤولين
للاشراف على تسريح وتجهيز القوات
الاوكرانيه استعدادا للهجوم المضاد بحسب
صحيفه
وبالعوده للتسريبات فقد كشفت ان اوكرانيا
خططت لشم ضربات على الاراضي الروسيه في
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الماضي في ذكرى
بدايه الحرب الا انها امتنعت عن ذلك بناء
على طلب من واشنطن بحسب واشنطن
ونزلنا في مجال التسريبات لكن البوصله
الامريكيه ت هذه المره الى فرنسا حيث
اشارت وكاله ان الاداره الامريكيه مستاءه
من الجهود الدبلوماسيه التي يبذلها الرئيس
الفرنسي لحل ازمه اوكرانيا التوتر يتصاعد
بين واشنطن وباريس فكيف سينعكس هذا التوتر
على الازمه الاوكرانيه وبين هذا وذاك اكدت
الخارجيه الهنغاريه انها لن تدعم حتى
العقوبات الجزئيه ضد الطاقه النوويه
الروسيه
السودان يشتعل هدنه لم تكتمل وحرب تعود
للواجهه ليعود السودانيون الى الصراعات
المباشره ليجتمع في لوكسمبرج وزراء خارجيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي للبحث في ملفات ابرزها
عمليات اجلاء ما تبقى من الرعايه
الاوروبيين من السودان فهل هو هروب من
الجحيم السوداني نعم يا ساده فها هو
الدخان يتصاعد بكثافه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت السلطات الامريكيه ان طائرا اصطدم
بطائره ركاب وتسبب في اندلاع حريق بمحركها
بعد وقت قصير من اقلاعها من مطار اوهايو
شعبيه مكون في خطر حيث اظهر استطلاع
للرائي ان اكثر من 70% من الفرنسيين غير
راضيين عن اداء الرئيس ايمانويل الذي
تقترب شعبيته من ادنى مستوياتها في تراجع
يعود بشكل رئيسي الى اصلاح نظام التقاعد
المثير للجدل اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي فرض
عقوبات على 25 شخصا وثماني منظمات في
سوريا في تومه تورطهم في تهريب المخدرات
اشار تقرير معهد استوقلم الدولي للابحاث
والسلام الا ان المغرب انفق خمسه مليارات
دولار على التسلح خلال 2022 اصبحت الشركه
الفرنسيه المصنعه للسلع الفاخره
ولا شركه اوروبيه
قيمتها السوقيه نصف تريليون دولار وجاء
ذلك مع الصعود القياسي للسهم مشاركه
امريكا في الحرب الاوكرانيه تقرب العالم
من حرب خطيره بين اقوى دولتين في العالم
برايكم هل اقتربت نهايه العالم
[موسيقى]